[Music]
hello people watching this I'm Tilda
Swinton and I'm in London today shooting
with GQ okay two questions about my past
tell me your name Katherine Matilda
Swinton where did you grow up tricky one
lots of different places but mainly in
Scotland who would you nominate as man
of the year uh I would say that's a
pretty dead tie between my father who is
89 is going to be 90 next year and my
sweetheart Sandra who is pretty awesome
in every way what about the woman of the
year I would have to say my daughter
Anna who is sitting over
there who's 17 tomorrow my song of the
year of course Everything is Awesome
Everything Is Awesome from my movie of
the year The Lego Movie and you are
right my TV show of the year Well we
don't have a t TV so we're always a
little behind the curve on TV shows this
year I would say vep God bless you
Etc so we're fairly up to date if you
could sum 2014 up in one word what would
it be nice really nice year if you could
get a doover of one moment of this year
what would it be
oo oh
dear I sitting here right now under the
pressure of the camera wearing and the
clock I can't think of one thing which
is pretty good so that's that thank
[Music]
you